à première vue ce feeling on est une
joueuse de volley dans l'élite comme les
autres au deuxième coup d'oeil on voit
encore une joueuse élites comme les
autres même s'il est né avec une
malformation à la main droite
je m'adapte
[Musique]
le mcs sexuellement les athlètes sont
beaucoup plus à l'aise à bondy c'est
avec elle que les entraîneurs que les
adultes la glace se brise pas comment
s'établit à cheney comme ça puis après
saw 6 pouces à l'arrêt de ses déliés
à 16 ans elle est l'une des plus jeunes
au camp d'entraînement de l'équipe du
québec
bien qu'un peu timide elle fait sa place
à coups d'attaqués et de blocs sa grande
taille sa rapidité sur le terrain et son
impulsion sont ses plus grandes forces
je pense que ça a été un hacker qui
touchait plus haut
mais il mérite une première année je
crois pas qu'il y en ait qui touche plus
au cinéma au québec points avec ou sans
manches donc ça c'est quelque chose
c'est quand même assez exceptionnel
ces points ferait tout pour elle on
dirait que c'est juste naturel pour elle
de continuer malgré cela elle frappe de
la main gauche une bénédiction volley
ball où les gauchères sont rares sont
droites faction comme positionner peau
les droits
151 et j'ai vu quand mon temps je pars
chercher comme des places comme
la joueuse de saint lazare qui rage au
cégep édouard montpetit cet automne à
pratiquer plusieurs sports dont le
soccer le plongeon et le ski mais elle
préfère la camaraderie djoliba
l'équipe c'est quand on célèbre un point
j'aurai toujours le fun est ainsi quand
conférer bon coup quand les autres
niveaux coup andré septembre que
stéphane février un coût d usage sophie
ne sais pas jusqu'où la mènera son sport
et le vit au jour le jour mais à court
terme elle aimerait que l'équipe du
québec monte sur le podium aux jeux du
canada et si antoine et et radio canada